alcohol addiction is a growing problem  in this world and alcohol is the most  popular drink throughout this world but  why alcohol is so addictive and what is  the biology behind that people say it  comes them down or it feels really good  but how does alcohol affects our brain  so alcohol actually induces the gabergic  signaling and thereby slows down the  overall brain activity you feel sedated  it works like a sedative  now alcohol also affects a dopaminergic  pathway known as mesolimic pathway this  pathway is well known for its reward and  pleasure seeking behavior that means our  brain just wants more it always says it  feels good I want more and more alcohol  and thereby you slowly get addicted  now alcohol has a lot of harmful effect  it affects your reproductive Health it  affect pregnant women in various aspects  so let's say no to alcohol